let's talk about where we end up going
when you have this hyper partisanship we
have larry sabato
red alert
52 percent of trump voters somewhat or
strongly favor blue states seceding to
form a separate country
41 percent of biden voters want the red
states to do the same
strongly 25 percent of trump voters
strongly feel this way and 80 of biden
voters
just look at look at the report
and uh that's
basically it
more than half of trump supporters are
like democrats go do your own thing
almost half a democrat saying the same
thing i i think it's beautiful and i can
be unlike some other libertarians in
this regard in the sense that like i
don't view libertarianism as like some
objectively correct philosophy i view it
as the way that i want to live right
like i think it's bad that communists
aren't allowed to be communist i think
they'll be very unhappy i don't think
they're they're but i'm not trying to
take it away from them i don't think
that they're wrong right i think they'll
be very very happy yeah i really really
i hope they are i hope they are like
look at california yeah they vote for
the same thing over and over no matter
how bad it gets because they like it
it's good for them they can have it i'm
out i'm not gonna be there so like let's
let people sort themselves out let's let
people live according to their values
like we'll all be happier so i you know
i think that's a huge white pill i think
we should be optimistic when we hear
that well i certainly think that you
know people have mentioned the peaceful
divorce because it's the
the alternative to violent separation so
yeah definitely and be it uh texas or
new hampshire
i i'm i'm all for self-determination it
would it would be really interesting we
actually had a debate on what would
happen
with texas and new hampshire if they
tried to secede we talked a bit about
new hampshire we were like manchester
will get occupied by the feds the major
urban center so they're not going to let
that go the roads would be shut down
what do you think would happen if new
hampshire said yo we out
i'm i'm actually quite skeptical of the
federal government's ability to like do
something strong here um at least
anything strong in the sense of like
actually sending in troops actually
exerting force i think if the federal
government was against it you'd much
more likely see a response that's like
and i'm not saying that this wouldn't be
very impactful but like attempting to
shut down trade attempting to shut down
the borders outside of the state uh or
attempting to make things hard on people
uh going in and out rather than actually
i think i think there is zero chance
regardless of what state succeeds that
there that there would be troops sent in
well what do you what do you think the
fed's maybe not zero but uh what what do
i think they would do
some of the things i'm talking about
right like i think they would attempt to
make it hard for people to get in and
out i think that's like plausible so in
the surrounding states they'd set up
checkpoints
yeah on the roads and stuff like that
that'd be like i-95 north yeah yeah
which we have to leave as federal
government property oh all the freeways
are federal well no no i mean maine
needs to be able to get to the rest of
the u.s so and then there's all the
federal buildings and federal employees
the post office no those are those are
ours
the post office yeah no we're gonna take
those
exactly someone was like ian why are you
so hard on because i think it's a
terrible idea to be like we out um i am
into other ways i'll mention in a minute
but someone was like why are you so down
on it these people that want us to see
don't want to take anything and i was
like well they want to take land they
want the united the federal government's
land well we'll get we'll distribute it
to the population like what happened in
afghanistan i mean so like the people in
new hampshire will be that much richer
because we'll get to take all this
federal property distribute it
amongst the citizens i guess i guess i
feel like any kind of seizure of federal
property could get violent really fast
yeah maybe we'll pay them look you know
i think the play is concentrate people
leverage nullification and then if the
federal government gets aggressive with
you
then you push secession but i'm all for
i'm not like i'm for succeeding now i'll
do it tomorrow what i've been thinking
about is creating a parallel system that
can operate through the united states
federal government without it
so like a new economy that works
alongside go for it sorry i want people
to see this image right here that just
pulled up
this is a post office in tilton new
hampshire
and uh i just think you know when you
say we'll take it
it reminds me of fort sumter
you know the union troops are there and
you got all these post offices so i'm
just is is it going to be you know like
the historic battle of tilton
i'm trolling a little bit when i say
when i say that we'll take it i think
the goal is to keep it as peaceful as
possible so if we need to buy the
property from the federal government
then we can buy it
the post office there's a whole bunch
and then there's military bases yeah
so
would be really interesting to see what
would happen i think
if anything did happen it would probably
be this weird pseudo secession when the
federal government would still operate
within the borders of new hampshire
completely and totally as they normally
do i think that's the kind of thing that
would lead to conflict though well what
would happen is like you mentioned with
the amish they don't pay social security
tax or whatever the people of new
hampshire would basically vote and just
be like you know we out the federal
government would be like i guess we're
still going to keep using these bases in
this land and people in new hampshire
are going to be like don't care but you
can't get taxes from us anymore yeah
i'll take that deal
wasn't there there was a famous story
about a family in new hampshire they
didn't pay taxes do you remember that
story
yeah i can't remember the name but uh
they they ended up getting in like a
standoff with the federal government and
they yeah that's crazy yeah
so what happens when you have mass
non-compliance for how many people it's
like 1.3 million people or something
into place like new hampshire yeah
i think you win when you have mass
non-compliance that's what i think
happened like you'll have a siege so
it'll seem like you win at first and
then you'll slowly be choked out by like
economy and no travel no flight paths
over their thing no pollut if you have
pollution that goes over the borders boy
are you going to pay for that
i think i think i don't think you
understand what new hampshire is like
i think you're imagining new hampshire
is like new york with massive urban
requirements in this like very dense
like it's very difficult to get food you
can't grow food anywhere
new hampshire maybe like manchester it's
harder to do but most of the state is
just like
trees
and people are gonna have are they gonna
homestead i'd imagine also you have
ports so like even if they control the
roads it's much harder to you know
actually unless they're gonna like again
they'd have to start you know shooting
down boats in international waters that
are from other countries and from other
places and saying they can't come into
the port it is american uh us territory
though isn't it because of long island
the water is controlled by the u.s uh
i mean i'm sure again
this is this is all like very difficult
to kind of like very hypothetical very
good
to kind of to kind of larp out um i
think that like oh no no direct ocean
access yeah oh yeah yeah 13 miles of
coast um so not the largest amount of
coast but enough um and look i think i
think there's so much i'm not i'm not
trying to talk down secession i just
think there's so much more that you can
do you don't have to jump from where we
are today all the way to secession look
the more libertarians control the state
government they can repeal an incredible
amount of state laws they can make it
very hard for the federal government to
operate and we've already we already
have a roadmap for this
and and this is exactly what i was
talking about with this sour grapes
thing like
how many states have nullified federal
marijuana laws does the federal
government send in the or immigration
laws
sanctuary cities right all kinds of
cities literally nullify the federal
government doesn't send in troops to
stop that and so that's what you do like
and this isn't quite as sexy as the
seating tomorrow i understand so i i i
also want to talk about the the sexier
topic but you just go piece by piece and
so rather than going for trying to eat
the apple in one bite which causes a a
conflict you take one bite of the apple
and then they don't come out you take
another bite in the apple and you just
keep doing that until you've eaten the
whole apple and when each step is so
small that
force seems like a disproportionate
response they don't do it and then all
of a sudden you've eaten the entire
apple and so i think that's a much
better strategy yeah well so uh
what is there like a five-year plan do
you like or a better better question is
like what do you think happens in five
years
i think that libertarians continue to
concentrate i think we continue to have
more political power i'll talk briefly
about the political power we have
currently we have 40 elected free
staters to the state legislature we have
more than 100 libertarians total and
this is they're graded by a third this
is another one of the institutions in
this massive web of institutions that
are creating the liberty movement
there's an institution called the new
hampshire liberty alliance great
institution to support and they grade
every bill on whether it's libertarian
or not and then they grade
every representative in terms of did
they vote the libertarian way so we have
grades going back 15 years on maybe
longer on every politician and where
they libertarian so when i say there's
100 libertarians i'm saying there are
100 libertarians that got an a they
voted libertarian 90 of the time or more
on the on the bills in 2020. what if i
want a tank
do it i want a tank and i want a 50 cal
full auto i think if anyone deserves a
tank it's you so people don't realize
this but i love it tanks are legal
uh there's and depending on what kind of
weaponry you have on it and where you
have it it's illegal as well it was it's
funny because you often hear from from
these you know democrat establishment
types the authoritarians about gun
control and they're like you can't own a
tank can you and you're like yes you can
you literally can a story i i think was
buzzfeed that wrote this a guy had a 50
cal full auto on his on a tank and he
was shooting into a lake and some like
some state troopers pulled up and they
were like howdy and he was like he stops
and he's like how can i help you and
they're like this your property he's
like yes it is like have a nice day and
they left
i i'll plug new hampshire highest
machine gun
per capita wow really yeah highest
highest machine gun
auto machine
i'm pretty sure that video of luke with
two full auto
you know new hampshire you see the
picture of luke with his dog and a goat
yeah i hope he has more than one though
you're not supposed to have one goat
right yeah but you know you keep doing
you just keep doing stuff like this and
as we get more political control you get
more people in office you repeal more
laws you do more nullification type
stuff we you know there's so many clever
ways you can do it where you can just
like
you see we're doing this with guns now
where we're basically saying hey federal
agents can't operate in the state
they're just not allowed they'll be
breaking state law and you play these
guys
yeah exactly like it was a big thing in
ohio where they were like if any atf
agent tries to enforce us arrest them oh
yeah something like that right so you do
stuff like this and i and i think this
is the way that you can um you can win
what if we uh bought like 100 acres and
then just told people like have at it i
would be thrilled to to welcome you to
the free state tim i think i mean i
wouldn't we're we're out in west
virginia basically so we we actually are
just finalizing a deal on a big plot of
land um you know freedom city or
fredamastam we jokingly call it and
we're going to have like a recreational
facility and we're going to be producing
a lot of content doing more shows we
have a new show that's actually already
live i guess we can we can announce the
name now because it's already up isn't
it
we'll save it for tomorrow yeah
it is uh but you know we're gonna so we
soft launched it and then we can
officially announce it so we're doing a
bunch of shows and these are like fully
produced podcast editing sound effects
and stuff like that so we want to do
this mini little freedom city in west
virginia
but what if we just bought you know 100
acres in central new hampshire
if there was a group of people who are
willing to go there and just start using
it so i think if you're interested in
that in the chat if you could just sound
off and say yeah i want to i want to
move to new hampshire thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you